ajoute dans cette position un coup
complètement fou dame C7 mettant sa dame
en prise par toutes les pièces adverses
si on pourrait croire que le grand
maître allemand à rippé ou que son chat
s'est amusé avec sa souris en réalité la
partie s'est déroulée devant un vrai
échiquier alors qu'elle est donc l'idée
derrière ce coup Camille
tes chèques dame prend tour et après
tout reprendre c'est tout simplement un
mat du couloir si les Noirs décident de
capturer la dame avec leur propre dame
la même idée aboutit à la même punition
encore une fois c'est mat du couloir
plus complexe si l'autre tour capture la
dame les blancs font de nouveau
torroïques échecs dame prend tour tour
prend tout et là on se dit que les
Blancs ont raté leur chance puisqu'il
n'y a plus de matte du couloir mais le
Fou vient apporter sa pierre à l'édifice
fou des seins que l'échec un tournoi a
obligé de s'interposer et après fou
point F7 c'est un superbe mat délivré
par les pièces